you're looking at a glorious bird that
may just be the most unappreciated
creature on the African Serengeti this
is the rappels Griffon vulture I know I
know you hear the word vulture and all
these other words and phrases come up
scavenger death profiteer carcass
stripper but without the repels Griffon
vulture the serengeti would be one
colossal trashy these vultures are the
cleanup crew and they have many notable
virtues they're the most cooperative and
most social of all vultures they live
together in large colonies and tucked
into the sides of cliffs they mate for
life sharing parental duties both
parents incubate the egg and they both
eat and then regurgitate the meat they
serve their baby a full-grown rappels
vulture can weigh over 20 pounds it's a
huge bird that's an expert scavenger it
will sometimes fly over 90 miles looking
for a kill mmm this looks promising a
hungry lion takes a bead on a pair of
Congo knee species of antelope
the con Goni are distracted and the lion
takes full advantage
[Music]
the griffon vultures circle overhead
observing office knowing their timing
has to be just right they begin their
group descent believe it or not taking
down the antelope was the easy part for
the lion now it has to figure out a way
to hide the kill from all the beasts who
will try and take it away
the vultures land preparing their
assault just as the vultures are
watching the lion some hyenas are
watching the vultures the lion tries to
chase off the hyenas but a certain
number of hyenas equals critical mass
and the lion ends up having to ditch its
booty which means the vultures have an
entire fresh Congo knee carcass all to
themselves even the hyenas can't get
close when these vultures are dining at
nature's buffet table the hyenas get the
bum's rush when it comes time to share
the spoils in a battle okay now here's
the after shot of the carcass they left
barely a morsel in fact their fuel tanks
are so full they almost can't get
airborne but airborne they get and they
resume their natural duty first Airborne
Division of the Serengeti cleanup
squadron
[Music]